vous avez sûrement déjà entendu parler
d'eux
la légende veut qu'il soit à l'origine
de ce qu'on éprouve quand un baiser
d'air glacé no more le nez ou quand un
vent polaire transforme une fenêtre en
tableau noir où quand on a pas classe
parce qu'il a neigé jack pot control et
l'hiver la glace et la neige
il peut les modeler les plier à sa
volonté
il peut voler et il peut faire
d'extraordinaire boule de neige mais si
vous pensez que jack frost ne fait que
s'amuser et jouer avec la neige
alors vous ne le connaissez pas jack est
une légende qu'est ce qui vous fait
croire que je veux devenir une légende
ou en tout cas on aimerait qu'il le
devienne
jack va s'unir avec les autres légendes
nord le père noël bunny le lapin de
pâques fait la fée des dents et sable
marchand de sable pour défendre les
rêves et les enfants du monde entier
il vous suffit
croire et vous verrez qu'on a tous
besoin des légendes quoi j'ai fait une
grosse bêtise à tulle bat tous les
records